okay how many times is this it wasn't
just last year it wasn't the year but
i can't keep count of how many times you
guys have won
a few times i don't know i think it's
four somebody said four
it is four first one had to be great
the second one was like oh my gosh
should this happen again the third year
like really but the fourth time around
how does the fourth time around like
really really yeah
[Laughter]
really really really really really
really i mean this one definitely was
one we were like
we were i mean there's been a few times
where trevor's like called it for sure
that we were gonna win
personal here he gave us a guarantee but
this year he was silent or something
that's hard you know like it's just you
know you feel disconnected because we
you know we haven't been doing we
normally do
you know on the road and you know
feeling the energy of the music and kind
of the trajectory of the band and you
just kind of get a little lost and
it's just good to know that someone's
still thinking about it
i mean people are still thinking about
it a lot of people still thinking about
y'all because you're always on the radio
here in nashville and
across the country you know um and
you're just doing your thing so has this
time
inspired even more music and and hopes
for getting back out there on the road
what what is that looking like right now
for you guys
looking really good for us right now
like we have a we have a ray of hope
here a lot of raids aho we made up you
know we
wrote recorded a whole album so we've
got a lot of new music coming
we're getting there's an array of hopes
we're getting daily emails about new
shows that are coming in
so it's opening up by the end of this
year it's gonna
it's gonna be good i like it we need to
see the pedal put to the metal boys we
need old dominion back out there on the
road
that is a nice look at that statue right
there i could not get enough of it
look at that cowboy hat yeah
where did these awards go now that you
guys have accumulated so many
ebay yeah it's been a tough year
women were bad but has it always been a
cowboy hat on time yeah
yeah yeah but it's been like a day i
knew when she said that
i knew when she said that you were like
i was like
is there something behind me no but can
i tell you that
i thought the same thing because the old
version versus the it's like become an
extension of a cowboy
different iteration so i'll give you a
pass i did the same thing with the oak
ridge boys and they were like yeah the
old cowboy hat and i was like what
but congratulations guys who are y'all
looking forward to seeing perform
tonight i know things are looking a
little different you might have to watch
it from your tv
versus out in the audience yeah i know
you just kind of like caught a little
glimpse of
jerks playing the youtube yeah at
station in with foreign tree
i always loved a song about a dog too
that was pretty nice
[Music]